. All right, it's been a very, very big week
and much has happened.
We have a new president, we have a new vice
president.
Donald Trump fled Washington, D.C. in shame
on Wednesday.
All very exciting.
And many people want to comment.
So let's go to what we call the phone lines,
even though they're really more like Internet
tubes at Dischord David Pakman dotcom slash
discord.
Let's go to our friends, Scott from Pensacola.
Even though every time the last time we went
to Scott from Pensacola, I have a friend,
Scott in Pensacola, he's never actually called
in at some other Scott in Pensacola.
Scott in Pensacola, you're on the air, yes,
you got me, yeah.
Excellent.
So the inauguration yesterday, what do you
make about them?
I guess the people on the right are crying
about how Garth Brooks decided that he wanted
to show for Joe Biden, but had a scheduling
conflict last time.
I couldn't care less.
Yeah, I mean, listen, I mentioned this during
the live stream earlier this week of the inauguration
where in 2016, 2017, Trump wanted Garth Brooks
and Garth Brooks said, sorry, I have a scheduling
conflict.
And it wasn't really clear whether he did.
And then Garth Brooks was invited this week
and he said, I'm doing it and I'm doing it
as a unity statement, not as a political statement.
And of course, many of us wondered, was it
really a scheduling conflict in 2017 or did
he simply not want anything to do with that,
with Donald Trump?
I don't know the answer, but to the extent
that right wingers are focused on it, I don't
care.
It's such a minor issue.
Do you think he was successful in making a
unity statement with it?
I was Garth Brooks successful or was the Biden
inaugural a strong unity statement?
The inaugural more so, yeah, I mean, listen
here, here's the thing, Joe Biden did so much
more on Wednesday than anyone deserved, given
the divisive and weaponized disinformation
nature of the last four years.
Now, given that Biden did it, is it likely
that we're now going to have unity with these
obstructionist Republicans?
No, but Biden did it.
Just because it won't work, because the Republicans
won't go for it doesn't mean Biden was wrong
to say let's come together and I'm everybody's
president.
So I think Biden did a good job.
I don't think it'll go anywhere.
And one last question before I let you go,
what do you think just sort of as a normal
person I can do or generally people in the
audience can do to kind of keep colleagues
or friends from sort of tuning out and going
to brunch as I've heard it.
But I mean, I think I think the most important
message is nothing's happened yet.
Biden now can do stuff, but nothing's happened
yet.
And of course, he's gotten some executive
orders done.
So things are starting to happen.
But I think the message needs to be the last
four years, we didn't even have a shot at
getting anything done.
Now we have a shot at getting things done.
But imagine that whenever you get the ball
back in football, you stop playing because
you think you score points by getting the
ball.
You would be very wrong.
Once you get the ball, you've got to score
the points.
That's where we are now.
Gotcha.
Well, thanks for your time.
My pleasure, Scott.
From Pensacola, always great to hear from
our friends
in Pensacola.